less than two weeks from the beginning
of hybrid learning for some secondary
clark county school district students
various teachers are taking some issues
with the new schedule
eight news now reporter kristen drummond
live in our newsroom with some of those
teacher concerns kristen
brian i spoke with a few high school
teachers and they
questioned the hybrid plan it's a
significant adjustment and some
challenge the feasibility of the various
components
am i excited about hybrid teaching no i
think it's a disaster
as far as the timing schedule is
concerned candidness from ccsd high
school teachers
when educators look at this in the
beginning they try to make sense out of
it
we kind of laugh as well as cry
revealing their issues with the hybrid
schedule for secondary
schools we don't really know how we're
going to do it yet the district plans to
split
students among three cohorts a b and c
those in a or b switch going to campus
on two different days
during the week cohort c remains
full-time distance education
but those attending class in person only
take
two courses before completing the school
day remotely
the schedule also changes each week to
make all periods available
at some point for face-to-face
instruction i printed mine out because
we have a green week and a blue week
this hybrid schedule it just doesn't
seem ideal that's an understatement jim
frazee is vice president of the clark
county education association
and a high school teacher he adds the
plan requires him
to readjust his lessons look at a class
period that goes from
an hour to an hour 45 minutes and the
pacing
of that is obviously night and day some
anticipate
not many students returning this
semester a lot of kids wanted to change
from a and b
into c because the hybrid schedule is
kind of
strange literally i'm only having four
five six students in a class
changes as educators prepare for another
transition
we're going to make the best out of it i
reached out to ccea
regarding the educator's concerns the
teachers union tells me
the agreement with the district focuses
on a manageable workload and
each school has the flexibility to
adjust if issues come up
visit our website 8newsnow.com to see
their full statement
reporting live in the newsroom kristen
drummond 8 news now